repart en ukraine avec un entretien
exclusif bonjour cyril payen vous êtes
l'envoyé spécial de france 24 et vous
vous trouvez au côté de l'ambassadeur
français en ukraine à kiev
merci julien oui effectivement bienvenue
à kiev
cette capitale ukrainienne qui entre
dans son quatrième mois depuis le début
de l'invasion militaire russe où il fait
extrêmement beau ce qui est un peu une
idée ça donne une idée un de cette
résilience ici qu'on voit avec beaucoup
d'ukrainiens qui tentent de relever seul
ambassadeur de france bonjour etienne de
poncins merci d'accès d'avoir accepté
notre invitation non soir alors vous
êtes un des protagonistes cette crise
vous êtes vous avez été nommé en janvier
dernier
est ce que on est à la croisée de
chemins est ce qu'il ya un premier bilan
selon vo à tirer de cette guerre le
premier bilan vous l'avez dit c'est
l'extraordinaire résilience et
résistance des ukrainiens nous sommes
donc effectivement après trois mois à
deux guerres et la résistance est
toujours aussi farouche aussi déterminé
de toute la nation ukrainienne qui s'est
levé comme un seul homme si je peux
reprendre cette expression le 24 février
au matin lorsqu'elle a été agressée par
par les troupes russes ça vous a surpris
à la fois cette ce déclenchement de
cette guerre parce que conventionnel qui
a pris beaucoup de gens par surprise
est-ce que vous même qui vivait ici
avait été surpris par cela surpris c'est
l'ampleur a surpris très certainement eu
un effet de sidération puisqu'on n'avait
pas vu de tels conflits et sur le
continent européen depuis près d'un
siècle la dernière référence était celle
de l'invasion de la pologne par
l'allemagne nazie en 1939 donc sa
remontée et heureusement après la part
la résistance ukrainienne non parce que
je connaissais bien ce pays
allez partout dans toutes les villes y
compris à l'est et je savais je
subodorais même si on peut jamais être
sûr à 100% qu'il y aurait très
certainement une résistance farouche et
que n'avait aucune raison que les russes
puissent prendre kiev notamment quelques
jours comme c'était apparemment leur
plan est donc que monsieur l'ambassadeur
précisément est-ce que comment
explique-t-on ce formidable malentendu
je dirais des stratèges de vladimir
poutine c'est difficile à dire pour le
moment un mauvais renseignements une
mauvaise appréciation peut-être qu'il
pensait
l'ukraine il ya 20 ans ou 30 ans mais
l'ukraine est un pays qui a beaucoup
évolué ces dernières années qui avaient
célébré avec beaucoup de patriotisme
d'ailleurs ses 30 ans de l'indépendance
en août dernier et d'ukraine que
monsieur jean a en tête probablement pas
l ukraine aujourd'hui l'ukraine de 2022
quand vous l'ambassade ainsi que
l'ensemble des chancelleries
occidentales et autres ont quitté kiev
dans des conditions difficiles puisque
les forces russes et est on s'en
souvient au porte de kiev est ce que ça
vous a surpris que kiev ne tombe pas
finalement puisque c'était vraiment
presque presque accomplie il était à
bout de chasteaux mais les airs pin
c'est-à-dire à à 15 km à l'ouest de là
où on est aujourd'hui oui à 15
kilomètres mais enfin la ville est
grande comme vous comme vous le savez
est très vaste
nous nous avons toujours pensé que ce
serait quand même difficile de prendre
une ville si elle n'était pas d'accord
et ce qui était le cas comme ça avec
même trente trente mille hommes enfin
c'est à une agglomération de 4 millions
d'habitants très très très étendue avec
un grand fleuve qui l'a qui la
traversent donc je pense que c'était un
peu présomptueux de la part des russes
d'imaginer qu'en quelques jours il
prendra la ville vous savez qu'ils
avaient leur uniforme de parade dans
leur sac à dos pour venir défiler à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ici sur
le boulevard crèche à tiques tout ça
était difficile à concevoir alors
aujourd'hui on voit bien que kiev a été
épargné l'offensive soir qui elle aussi
ne se passe pas comme l'a dit
beyrouthine l'aurait souhaité
on est dans une période de contre
offensive voire d'offensive tati des
forces du crânienne ne parlons pas trop
vite puisque personne n'a vraiment gagné
ni perdu la guerre évidemment mais
est-ce que vous pensez que du côté
ukrainien on a l'ascendant aujourd'hui
notamment dans les zones dont j'ai parlé
c'est difficile à dire parce que le vrai
combat aujourd'hui dans le donbass comme
nous l'indiqué où là il ya le gros des
forces russes et le gros des forces
l'ukrainienne ce qui est sûr c'est que
la prise de kiev n'a pas eu lieu la
prise de kharkiv aussi l'aider à chaque
fois les forces chrétiennes ont réussi à
repousser au delà des frontières c'est
fait pour kiev s'est encore un peu plus
compliqué pour pour kharkiv ça c'est des
victoires si on peut dire mais des
victoires partielles évidemment le
principal combat est à venir et il est
dans le donbass vous pensez que les
ukrainiens ont une des ressources
suffisantes pour repousser l'armée russe
puisque c'était vraiment ce qu'on entend
ici on veut pas avoir un statu quo on
veut repousser les russes des rues les
ukrainiens sont confiants c'est clair
ils le disent il ya une formidable ma
forme et la bndes solidarité de défense
ils les reçoivent beaucoup de soutiens y
compris des deux de nous-mêmes français
y compris militaires soutien humanitaire
et c'est donc mon sentiment c'est
difficile à dire mais c'est que le temps
travaille pas un plus tôt pour l'ukraine
plutôt que pour les russes mais ça reste
encore à confirmer alors justement dans
cette hypothèse on sait que
l'ania poutine est difficilement on a du
mal à le suivre dans son dessin dans sa
stratégie est-ce que la menace nucléaire
quelque chose pour vous de tangible on
ne prend pas à la légère moi j'ai un
master de france en ukraine donc je
commande pas spécifiquement c'est ce que
les chancelleries je dirais et prennent
cette menace sérieusement il faut
demander à mes amer et mes collègues
forcément on la prend sérieusement
nucléaire on ne peut pas l'aborder
autrement que sérieusement je vous dit
personne ne peut faire ça sur le reste
c'était cd succès des supputations on
voit que ce qui va être déterminant à
sète au moment où on fait d'une forme de
bilan on l'a dit avec une
contre-offensive ukrainienne que la
communauté internationale dans son
soutien est absolument déterminante joe
biden à washington vient de débloquer
beaucoup d'argent 40 milliards de
dollars ce n'est pas la première fois on
sent qu'il ya une impulsion on sent
aussi auprès des du gouvernement du
volet numérique zelensky qu'on
demanderait un peu plus à l'europe un
peu plus à la france
est-ce que c'est justifié comme critique
à mots voilés il écoute je crois pas que
cela les critiques parce que la france
et l'europe ont fait énormément comme
vous savez pour la pour la première fois
je dirais l'union européenne a accepté
de mettre des milliards d'euros de
l'armement ce qui n'est pas sa vocation
première puisque c'est quand même une
organisation économique au départ la
france a fait beaucoup aussi à la fois
en aide financière en aide militaire
l'avantagent de l'ambassade d'avoir
d'être restés présents sur le sol
ukrainien est justement d'avoir été au
plus près des demandes ukrainienne nous
sommes en contact permanent avec les
ministères le ministre
et nous prenons en compte exactement ce
qu'il souhaite et nous leur apportons
exactement l'aide qu'il demande très
précises vous aviez vu par exemple est
sûre les canons c'était une demande
précise fait par le président et nasty
au président macro et nous l'avons mise
en place et c'est justement un des gros
avantages d'avoir cette ambassade de
france en ukraine présente depuis le
début et qui n'a jamais quitté le sol du
crime mais monsieur l'ambassadeur vous
savez évidemment on reproche à monsieur
au président macron son rôle de
médiateur auquel ils semblent attachés
tout le monde en parle ici on dit qu'il
faudrait qu'ils rompent toute forme de
discussion avec le président russe tu
compenses et beaucoup de commentaires à
faire là-dessus si ce n'est qu' il est
en contact constant avec le présent
zélande ce qui est que tous les contacts
qu'il a pu avoir c'est ça a toujours été
fait en complète transparence avec le
président et vince qui est souvent à la
demande même du presse du président
zeller ski je vois qu'il ya une
confiance qui existait déjà avant la
guerre entre nos deux présidents qui est
quelque chose de remarquable et qui est
un atout à la fois pour l'ukraine est
aussi pour eux pour la france alors
rapidement avant de avant de rendre
l'antenne vous revenez de paris est ce
que vous pouvez nous annoncer quand le
président français va venir non j'ai
beaucoup de contacts mais je crois que
c'est encore en examen à paris il est
attendu ici il le sait il est venu tout
au début de la crise un il est venu le 9
février donc et encore une fois il ya ce
contact quasi bi hebdomadaire entre nos
deux présidents qui font qu'il ya
vraiment une fluidité des échanges entre
entre paris et kiev qui est tout à fait
remarquable tout à fait exceptionnel
vous qui avez vécu au coeur de cette
crise dont vous avez dit c'est la
dimension été totalement inédite à 1
quand on peut rennes est ce que vous ne
craignez pas qu'il ya un essoufflement
de sympathie de envers le peuple
ukrainien dans l'opinion jusque là fait
on va rentrer dans le quatrième mois
est-ce que c'est pas aussi un problème
dans cette guerre de l'information que
se livrent moscou et kiev sur ceux de
dans ce domaine je crois pas parce que
ce que vit le peuple ukrainien est
tellement affreux ont notamment les
crimes que vous avez mentionné plus qui
s'ajoute à l'agression qui s'ajoutent
aux martyrs des villes comme marioupol
cerné dit vous autres il ya eu un tel
élan de solidarité en france dans tout
le monde occidental au moins en
direction du peuple ukrainien que je
pense pas qu'yves akiva qui va
s'essouffler il va y avoir d'autres
sujets et c'est logique c'est la vie qui
veut ça mais le l'élan va se poursuivre
et de toute façon du côté des autorités
françaises vous dire qu'elles sont
continue à être totalement mobilisée que
ce soit le président de la république
sous la nouvelle mini des affaires
étrangères madame colonna tout le monde
est déjà entièrement mobilisée pour
aider l'ukraine pour exprimer notre
solidarité pour lui apporter tout le
soutien dont il a besoin dans cette
épreuve encore une fois assez
extraordinaire au sens au sens propre du
terme extraordinaire c'est aussi la
nature des crimes dont on commence à
déceler l'impact terrible dans les zones
évidemment de l'ouest de l'ukraine mais
gzale également dans le dos près de la
frontière biélorusse dont on commence à
comprendre les français sont présents
d'ailleurs que font-ils exactement pour
aider la procureure nous avons été les
premiers présents avec une délégation de
gendarmes légiste parmi les meilleurs
les meilleurs du monde nous avons ouvert
le chemin beaucoup de nos partenaires
nous interroge d'ailleurs on peut le
faire la même chose prendre le relais
nous avons reconduit la mission première
mission est parti une deuxième arrive
pour l'instant elle était sûre kiev
cette mission de gendarmes à elle va se
déplacer plus à l'est dans la région de
thiers négative que sont-ils exactement
quel ce qu'ils y ont alors cédé des
médecins légistes donc on a des
notamment un laboratoire adn ils ont une
capacité de traitement de l'adn plus
moderne plus rapide plus efficace que ce
qu'avaient les ukrainiens d'ailleurs on
va leur fournir le laboratoire que nous
l'avons amené un peu en démonstration je
veux dire il reviendra bientôt en
ukraine et ceux qui vont aller at yani
guy ville vont être plus sur des
questions de balistique
parce qu'il ya un besoin il ya une
demande ukrainienne en ce sens et donc à
chaque fois on répond précisément à la
demande ukrainienne et surtout on y
répond rapidement puisque entre la
demande venue de ces gendarmes et leur
arrivée c'était cool et quinze jours à
peu près ce qu'est vraiment considérer
ce qui est vraiment très peu quand les
regards des premiers témoignages
concoctons a qui sont absolument
effroyable je rappelle des centaines de
viols des disparitions des tueries et ce
n'est que le début puisque on imagine ce
qui peut se passer actuellement dans les
zones
occupée est ce qu'un pays selon vous ce
pays où vous vivez peut se remettre de
ce genre d'exactions aussi terrible ce
sera très long c'est ce clerc qui a
maintenant une rivière de sang entre les
deux peuples entre le peuple ukrainien
et le peuple russes ce sera long ça
prendra des pôles en des décennies ce
que je crains c'est que ces enfants qui
ont vu leur père ou leur mère
subir ceux de tel sort ce sera difficile
pour eux après ce peuple est très
résilient il a subi déjà beaucoup de
traumatismes dans l'histoire du 20e
siècle je pense à la à la shoah par
balles ou à la grande famine de 1932
1933 il faut toujours être optimiste et
faire confiance à la nature humaine mais
c'est clair que ce que le peuple
ukrainien est en train de traverser
aujourd'hui est absolument terrible
comme comme souffrances endurées et vous
vous êtes un diplomate chevronné en tant
qu'homme comment ce qu'on traverse une
telle épreuve puisque c'est extrêmement
compliqué on est tous touchés on est
tous touchés vous l'être je le suis je
suis allé à butch à je suis allé à
airprint et rencontrer les familles
c'est dur c'est dur voir ce qu'ils ont
subi ce crime qui était absolument à la
fois inqualifiable et ce en raison des
gens étaient tués comme ça sans raison
dans la rue par des soldats russes
éméché housse ou non peut en vouloir à
venir poutine pour cela
oui j'ai forcément peur en vouloir aux
responsables ça c'est clair à ceux qui
ont qui ont laissé faire tiens deux
concerts hip c'est que nous sommes ou
2022 et ce type de crime on pensait que
c'était derrière nous que ça datait de
la seconde guerre mondiale et ses
revenus en plein 21ème siècle oui c'est
dur sur un plan personnel c'est dur
détiennent de concert je remercie m sur
le baladeur
voilà le cette interview exclusive avec
l'ambassadeur de france à kiev qu'on
remercie pour nous avoir livré ce
témoignage retour à paris julien les
programmes continus sur l'antenne en
français en anglais en espagnol et en
arabe et merci à vous